bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors racontez nous combien
de réfugiés afghans etes-vous en
capacité d'accueillir et comment comptez
vous organiser cet accueil
en fait on parle souvent de chez nous à
part de
d'opérationnalité parce que pour
l'instant on ne sait pas exactement
combien d'accords réussir un passé la
frontière être dans le circuit français
est arrivé jusqu'au nos territoires nos
collectivités
nous avons dit à monsieur macron que
nous étions capacité de mettre en oeuvre
un hébergement d'urgence pour les
accueillir et tout l'accompagnement qui
doit être
organisée et donc c'est la demande qui
est fait c'est de travailler ensemble
pour pouvoir accueillir les meilleures
conditions des personnes qui sont en
très grave danger parce que nous serons
tous dans un statut des réfugiés étant
donné la situation critique dans
laquelle il se trouve parce que ça fait
aussi partie du devoir de la france
d'accueillir des réfugiés qui quittent
un pays en proie à la guerre
bien sûr c'est même dans notre
constitution nous sommes fiers et nous
l'avons toujours été notre président l'a
déjà souvent d'ailleurs relier aussi
nous sommes un pays de droit d'asile est
un droit ça s'exercent pour tous ceux
qui ont les conditions dans lesquelles
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs les cinq ans ce
trop les aygalades cinq années de lacan
évidemment ça veut pas dire que
l'ensemble des afghans vont se déplacer
unis même venir tout seul en france et
puis on sait très bien qu'un pays comme
l'afghanistan va pas non plus être dans
la facilitation on vient de le dire on
vient de lui dire de votre dans votre
documentaire et donc nous sommes
simplement là en train de dire que dans
un état d'urgence dans lequel nous
trouvons pour un pays en état de guerre
eh bien les collectivités sont prêtes à
s'organiser pour accueillir des
personnes en grave danger
comment expliquer alors cette phrase
des manuels macron qui a fait polémique
un lundi soir nous protéger face aux
flux migratoires irréguliers alors il
s'est corrigé sur twitter le président
de la république quelques heures après
avoir prononcé ces mots il est déclare
enfin il a clarifié ses propos il a
dénoncé le comportement de certains de
vouloir détourner ces propos est-ce que
c'est le cas selon vous on a voulu
détourner les propos du président de la
république c'est une maladresse ou est
ce que ce sont des propos volontairement
10 de sa part
moi je suis rarement dans la
surinterprétation j'entends des propos
qui sont des propos qu'ils sont loin
d'être anodin puisque on est en train de
parler du droit d'asile en en train de
parler de l'année tagheer donc on n'est
pas dans une situation de fuir régulier
et flux qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'en réalité on est en train
d'envisager un nombre est important
alors moi je rappelle quand même que par
exemple quand la syrie a vécu ce moment
de guerre où il ya énormément de
personnes qui se sont déplacées
effectivement ce sont de grandes nombre
de personnes qui sont qui ont été remis
à être accueilli dans les pays voisins
mais aussi dans d'autres pays et dans
les notes en particulier
donc moi je réponds tu que la ville de
lar que l'état français ne soit pas en
capacité de répondre à un moment où à un
moment et but comme celui de ses prises
du régime taliban d'une d'un pays qui
était déjà un difficile puisque nous
avons nous déjà sur nos territoires
certains d'avant qui avait fuit déjà un
pays difficile mais qui rentre là dans
quelque chose d'encore beaucoup plus dur
violent et qui encore une fois mais les
gens en danger est ce que la france a
réellement la volonté la capacité de
vouloir accueillir ces réfugiés on a vu
ces derniers mois ces dernières années
ces images assez
assez choquant un de réfugiés de
migrants à qui on a confisqué leurs
tentes qu'on a expulsé de part et
d'autre vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
qu'il ya eu plusieurs manifestations
ces derniers mois notamment cet hiver de
migrants qui appelle qui interpelle le
gouvernement est bien pour avoir de
meilleures conditions de vie
bien sûr oui mais on n'est pas bien sûr
toutes les collectivités connaissent
bien la situation de ces enfants qui
viennent sur notre territoire qui
demandera statut de réfugié qui ont eu
énormément de difficultés à faire
reconnaître la situation dans laquelle
ils sont donc aujourd'hui on nous
explique que l'on facilite l'accès au
visage et donc à une forme de
régularisation
je le dis tout de suite pour l'instant
je n'en connais pas les chiffres exacts
mais en tout cas c'est un réajustement
tout à fait au portant en attendant des
afghans étaient déjà dans une situation
extrêmement critique et qu'il avait
énormément de mal à acquérir des pays
papier anne vignot merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes maire europe ecologie les verts de
la ville de besançon